[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades
we are already seven seasons deep into
fortnight Battle Royale and each week is
possible to tweak our gameplay with a
few handy tips and tricks whether your
ultra casual like me dedicated or a pro
in waiting here's 35 tips and tricks
from watching those professionals over
on Twitch I like to start these videos
off with a question this time what is
the greatest back bling in the game for
me it has to be the pink guitar although
that pink hamster is pretty dope too and
those wings oh man there's so many about
your favorites in the comments below
anyway enough jibber-jabber let's do
this the silent sniper rifle made its
debut in fortnight recently and due to
the reduced damage many people leaked
them behind a great way to use it is
with the balloons in tow and take to the
skies if you manage to get up there
without anyone noticing you can stay out
of sight and fire range and of course as
it's a silenced weapon people will not
know where you're shooting from this
works extremely well in the final circle
when players are in their towers closely
watching one another fly over their
heads and make them regret forgetting to
look up while we're in the air let's
talk about the storm weeks yes I know
everyone hates that I feel the same way
it's highly likely they will be nerfed
in future and I'd expect their whole
integrity that our overall HP to be
reduced so landing a plane will be
essential at present we all just jump
out and hope the plane lands nearby in
future try this hitting the brake or
reverse gear and pointing the nose of
the plane into the air if done correctly
it should look like this
carrying on from this I'm sure you've
noticed the plane has a reverse gear
well did you know it can reverse up
mountains mouths it's not a huge use for
this if you miss your landing on top of
a mountain I suppose you could reverse
back up but it actually works to
completely surprise your enemy when they
think they have the high ground and in
you show up like this
a quick note which I'm sure you already
know but just in case when switching
seats in the plane or any other vehicle
for that matter there is a slight delay
the time it takes for the character to
move into position this means we can
quickly toggle through multiple seats
before the animation triggers so go from
the wing all the way around to the
driver's seat without having to wait one
last one for storm wings and vehicles in
general the boom boxes can be placed
upon them to give them additional
destructive powers if the planes do lose
their ability to RAM structures this
could be a useful alternative oh there's
one more thing you should know about the
much hated planes you will not take any
fall damage if you land on their wings
regardless of height a few months back
we showed you how to hit crits through
the safety of walls in our example we
showed you how to safely destroy traps
well the community took this many steps
forward
first the scrims community began to make
windows in their structures to farm
trees and other materials without the
threat of taking a sniper bullet to the
face next it became apparent that this
technique works through all tiles so
here's a few ways to utilize this method
have you attempted to get inside an
opponent one by one by first climbing
their wall as your own this is what
usually happens to me yeah back to the
Lavi a safer way to do this is to first
pickaxe their wall then put up your own
ramp if you're quick enough the Crypt
will stay in the same place and you can
keep striking it let's hope you're
quicker to replace the wall this time
around Oh on the flipside of this when
being attacked and your opponent pushes
too close to your build it's possible to
shoot their hand when it passes through
the wall just like on battlefield 3 man
those were the days Zach and I were
testing structure strength and this
happened
and the wall is still fine prolonged
testing shoulders that it's possible to
kill people through all materials and
works on all body parts it's even
possible to headshot someone through a
wall if they've used an amount such as a
taunt which has phased through your wall
the optimal time to hit them is shortly
after they have fired a weapon this is
because the character holds the gun out
a little further just after shooting so
if you've been attacked but you've
managed to put up a wall in close combat
shoot back at the right time and they'll
think you're a crazy hacker and send you
abuse like this yeah I've been reported
oh I don't want to be reported what have
I done oh it's okay
I'm not reported anymore so at this
point we try to test if all the old
dirty stinking cheating methods to shoot
through structures worked again and to a
degree they do firstly there's a weak
spot on the last step of ramps which can
be shot through from below keep in mind
though it can work both ways so be
careful there's also a safe peak angle
yet again on the pyramids positioning is
far more difficult this time around
which should stop this from becoming an
issue but look the head hitbox is fully
protected food for thought and the best
of all fire docks if you weren't aware
doors and walls appear to take time to
open in fact there's only one frame of
difference between open and closed if
you know someone is behind that door
open it and shoot instantaneously the
shot will go through the door and take
off their face same thing with other
structures in the game like houses the
same second the door is activated it's
already opened so shoot through it at
this point I just wanted to say a quick
thank you to those who use my code a
tomorrow in the shop it really makes a
huge difference to what I can actually
produce so I salute you thank you all
very very much I appreciate it anyway
back to it ok let's move on to
engagements in and around builds have
you noticed there are two types of
defenders in this world those that spam
bills to keep you out and those who
count to shoot these are the people
we're looking at now those who allow you
to shoot out their wall and quickly try
to end your life with a C
shotgun pump to the face before
instantaneously putting up another wall
when attacking that type of foe
try to destroy their builds up to a
single bullet their inbuilt muscle
memory will cause them to shoot out
their own wall giving you that moment to
take a shot completely flipping the
table here's an insanely good bluff to
try when defending - and comes from
cypher PK who excels at rap plays he's
noticed that there's an opportunity to
relatively safe trap kill an opponent
when defending here's what he does he
begins by spamming defensive walls but
the moment there's a lull in the fight
for example when the opposition reloads
Seifer builds a ramp inside his
structure but quickly abandons it
editing it out of the way this step is
important as it causes a reaction in
your opponent they mirror your actions
they build a ramp to take the high
ground in that same moment
Seifer has already edited out of his
building and has combed his fault
killing him with traps high-level
shizzle but it's too good not to cover I
salute you sir as we all know there's
101 different ways to get inside an
opponent's build remember the method to
hit out the opponent's wall through your
own ramp while using that theory we can
also do this in this scenario the
opposition is turtling and we are trying
to get in from above they presume
rightly that you'll be taking out the
pyramid first but in fact here's what we
do we stand on the edge of the structure
and we can start hitting the roof tile
instead of the pyramid taking it out and
replacing it without them even realizing
then when we are able to take out the
pyramid we'll have any control of both
tiles usually allowing us to catch them
with their blueprints out completely
surprised by your ability to take the
roof tile without them knowing
I'm absolutely terrible at that by the
way so you could go old school like me
and pickaxe the top of their structure
you will slowly drop down into their
builds they can't stop this gravity is
on our side if it's done at the right
angle it's damn funny and as long as
they don't have traps it's an easy kill
let's quickly move away from build based
tricks and do some soft general
housekeeping always be aware that when
using a rift you can pick up another
item during the animation periods
another great recent inclusion is the
ability to switch weapons during the
animation no longer will you be forced
to land and switch weapon before you can
get in the fight do this pre-flight and
get back in the action if you're a
controller player who prefers medium to
long range encounters watch a streamer
named up shop he has perfected the
ability to abuse aim assist aim as you
would naturally but before each bullet
tap aim a millisecond before you'll hit
shots you didn't think we're possible
and you'll look like you know how to
fought night in 2019 let's keep going
with a few more general things when
running through the world we all
occasionally harvest on the go minimize
the slowdown when doing this by
switching to your weapon straight down
to your pickaxe hits you'll cancel the
slowdown animation and keep your
momentum up in places like tilted towers
or Paradise Palms take advantage of
doorways build a ramp to cover the door
when a foe opens the door edit the ramp
and take a free hit as though really
useful in early game and saves on maps
speaking of early game have you ever
dropped and seen every place you
originally wanted to go taken here's a
cool tip London verandas or bay windows
and even fire escapes you'll quickly
find landing spots that can claim floor
loops through windows to give you the
edge even when landing after everyone
else until to towers there's a great
spot on the fire escape to break through
the wall and take a few chests safely
before everyone on the roof finally
comes downstairs if there's such thing
as safe loot at tilted towers this must
be it when running from the storm or
attempting to catch up with teammates
who want bloody wait for you try this
technique if you can spare the mats
build a ramp over your head and jump the
ramp will give you a mini push and in
flat locations can make a huge
difference in speed
still to this day many of us neglect the
pyramid tile for transitioning through
Windows we all know by now about the
tilted towers windows we can use this on
but every single new location try to
take time to see whether pyramids work I
promise it's worth it here's another use
of the pyramid tile that I'm sure you're
already using quickly dropping them on
top of traps to stay safe and keep on
the move it's becoming commonplace by
now it's so commonplace in fact that is
possible to bait kills using these
pyramids by putting them over traps but
stopping the build from completing but
there is an issue now there's a
shimmering yellow light on structures
that are incomplete this means we are in
the last days the final days of being
able to kill people like this all the
memories the trap flaws gone but not
forgotten as Zac helped out so much on
this video let's showcase his current
favorite to play after trapping an enemy
like this Zac noticed that players fall
back to the opposite corner and begin to
pick acts out regardless of the heights
Zac waits for them and places down a
trap outside for them to eliminate
themselves on I personally think he's a
bully and therefore the hashtag Zac
sucks continues are you with me it's axe
axe and finally we found a reason to use
the present item aggressively in this
scenario our opponent is safely in their
little house if we can claim a wall and
run inside we can capture this entire
base using the gift the great thing here
is the fact that all the walls have
grooves the flaw they all now belong to
us place traps for added effect we call
this the present rush what do you think
so there we have it 35 quick tips to
think about when venturing into
fortnight whether you're a legend an
average player or a dirty casual like me
hopefully there's something for everyone
thanks for watching and the very special
thank you to those who use my code a
Demario in the shop we make a huge
difference to me and I really do
appreciate it I humbly thank you anyway
it's been a pleasure my name is Adam
from PlayStation granade passing next
time
[Music]